but the reshuffle wasn't all about women
there was a political character too and
in his column this week Charles Moore
says it wasn't the most suspicious one
in his words this must be the worst
reshuffle since mrs. Thatcher demoted
Jeffrey Howe in 1989
Charles is with me now Charles you've
seen a few reshuffles in your time what
made this one stand out well I thought
that it was the intention of it was to
punish bravery which is a mistake and no
doubt there's an electoral reason for
that but people who've caused
controversy and now want to quieten them
down in the coming election but
essentially if you run a department the
good ministers of the people who try to
do something and do do something and
have a name and essentially those are
the people who Cameron penalised most
notably though in Patterson whom he
sacked and Michael Gove whom he demoted
and they were very unusual in this
government in having a really clear
agenda that they had been trying to push
through and it's precisely because of
that that they were done down and of
course that's very bad for government
and I would have thought actually it's
not even good electorally because it's a
it's a mark of weakness you're giving in
there are very strong fierce opponents
of these people and they're gloating of
course but David Cameron would argue
that for everything there is a season
there's a time to reform a time to fight
members are time to consolidate and
focus on your key messages ahead of an
election and the greatest threat to
these reforms is labour government that
would reverse them well yes but it seems
to go against the message that the
government had been putting forward
recently which seemed to me very strong
simple message which is we are populist
policies being unpopular but essentially
they're working that time is on their
side they're coming right the economy is
coming right and we are a better lot of
people and policies than our opponents
very clear basic message so if you throw
up you use the metaphor of cards because
we talked about a reshuffle if you throw
the pack in the air and you limbs of
check out quite a lot you're saying
opposite message you're saying actually
it's all been pretty dingy and now it's
got to be different and I don't think
that's believable and I also think it's
unnecessary I don't see the I mean by
all means promote good women that's
that's well overdue but I don't see the
need to fasten on the people who've been
the boldest and punish them right but
the woman joins I mean politics that is
about optics you me lament the fact but
it's still it's still the factor well
it's certainly a factor yes right and
the David Cameron does have a problem
insofar as the Conservative Party's
brand is still rather tarnished people
don't quite like the idea of voting Tory
they tend not to admit to pollsters that
they do so surely in order to sell the
Tory message he does need to make the
face more acceptable and this is just
simply part of winning elections well
how credible is it I would ask you see
if you keep on saying how bad white
males are and sort of public school boys
and southerners and all the rest of it
how credibly can you say that if you are
one of them
which David Cameron is and George
Osborne's another and if you keep saying
you know women women women but actually
the heart of this government has no
women in it whatever I have there are
some women in important jobs but the
actual control of the government the
management the government the strategy
the politics the cabal who sits there
and decides everything a 100 percent
male and that remains the case so I
think this can be seen to be
fundamentally untrue this message and
people you know don't like fundamentally
untrue messages so I think if people
think these are tokens these are signs
of weakness because you feel bad about
what you are and you're not really
answering the point that's being made so
- so the argument of a party in
government as opposed to a party coming
into government is we know what we're
doing and we do it better than the
others and
we can prove results and these are
simple clear incumbency arguments and it
seems to me that's what they should
develop not not undermine but if you are
David Cameron you focus on the messages
that are working the economy message
that seems working and speaking up right
now and you even got welfare which is
very controversial but hugely popular
then you've got education where it's
more difficult to prove this is popular
and it's working for a start
education takes five or six years to
show of the reforms work or not you've
got the negatives the positives are some
years down the road and so doesn't it
can you not see damn it okay you may not
agree with it but can you not see the
logic this isn't a retreat from
radicalism is simply focusing on the
radicalism that is easier to persuade
the public what I can see the thinking
but I think it's mistaken because I
think what people looking for in all of
this is leadership and also concern
about major social issues and if Cameron
has believed in this schools policy
which he says he has then he should
double up on that not back away from it
and also in electoral terms I think
there's a massive gap here which is very
much to the point in the second event
Patterson the reason that you Kipp is so
strong is that there's a huge
disillusionment among people who are
rural people who are white males who are
fed up with being insulted simply for
being white males people who work in the
private sector and people who don't like
the dominance of sort of politically
correct London opinion and people who
are Euroskeptic and the only person in
the Conservative government who
absolutely tapped into all of those
factors is there in Paterson he's the
only chap who's never had a any career
in London at all except as a politician
he's a very private sector northern
businessman he knows a countryside very
well he's a true Euroskeptic as opposed
to a sort of fair whether you're a
skeptic that some of these recent
appointments are and actually this could
have been a sort of encapsulated message
to you Kipp voters from David Cameron
saying go on vote you Kipp you know he's
got this one sort of bulwark against all
that Patterson and he's but we have in
Philip Hammond a more Euroskeptic
Foreign Secretary than William Hague was
I've seen the departure of two
Europhiles M Ken chloric and Dominic
grieve the Attorney General so labour
certainly regards this as a move to the
right
yes you and I don't believe that because
I don't think Philip Hammond has very
strong views on them so he's he's
basically a moderate right winger but he
has no record on the European subject
apart from one or two remarks William
Hague was a great Euroskeptic before he
became foreign secretary and it made
very little difference you know what you
have to only your skepticism only means
something if you actually try to bring
about specific changes particularly
legal institutional changes